what's up theo brennan and gang i got
y'all playing right here
got a debate club for you all right
would you rather be
short like really short or
freakishly tall talking seriously talk
now mind you you might think okay
uh tall obviously right i'm six nine so
i know what kind of thing you can't find
shoes can't find clothes can't go on
airplanes traveling sucks so
let me know what y'all think gang gang
buzz buzz praise god brother praise god
praise god yeah jesus christ ori
you came in hot with this one what do
you think man oh tall
all day you can't find shoes that fit go
to a store go to the internet that's
easy
no you can't find anything cool though
like you like you hold up any any
designer shoe
the the max limits usually like 15. you
know you want to know what's cool
getting laid is cool really short like
all you can don't get laid
it's all he cares about is getting laid
but here's the it's a big portion
[Laughter]
get an suv get a pickup truck you can't
drive again
cool car what about ferraris lambos
porsches mclaren's
sacrifice but here's the thing and then
the airport thank you that's what i'm
saying first class
you're [ __ ] everything southwest when
you're six nine come on man and he got a
great voice
so were y'all saying little or big i
don't know what y'all are saying i'm
saying
you're saying little oh man
no tom cruise is short what about that
guy with no legs who shot his wife to
death
who's that
try playing sports when you're really
short not fun lacrosse
ufc um yep
155 and under you killing it one sport
uh jockey jockey okay
yeah there's not really i mean there's a
short baseball player what's the name uh
a
tuve the guy who just went for houston
yeah yeah yeah i mean cheater but yeah
yeah but he want mvp and he's short but
if you're tall hey you're gonna get more
ladies probably have a bigger ding dong
let's be real
but here's the thing imagine you show up
with that little baby jingle bell and
you're six
five baby like shaq huh jack has a tater
tot
it's well known but i don't know i've
heard that shaq has a real heat stick on
him no that's not true
really first of all i didn't hear that
neither one of us know and
that's good so i'm not gonna drop in
some facts
i'm not gonna argue about i don't wanna
ever
us to look back our children look back
and know here's my dad and
my dad's lying arguing about how big a
man's penis
when you're right you're wrong just look
at how small he is though
yeah but here's anything but i'm saying
if you're real tall and you got that
little baby jingle bell dog that thing
is gonna
disappoint you ladies even just grabbing
it with your hand
trying to get it like trying to get a
grape out of a big ditch yeah think
about that your [ __ ]
meat eaters are yeah big old dick
feeders
you reach down there you got that little
tater tot oh like trying to pick a
butterscotch out of dang garbage bag bro
these guys are all tall it's easy for
you to say the cons of being tall you
all got it i'm not tall
you're six foot six foot that's pretty
pretty good for good size
you're getting shorter you're a good
size you're like wrong look how five
nine i used to be average now i'm below
average the new average is 5 10.
tom cruise is five nine i think he's
even he's five he's like five six
every rapper is yeah anyway like so
that's and they get laid a lot so i'll
rather be short every rapper
but five nine isn't short sure when he
said really short that's five
four five six real short would be five
the baby the baby is five two
wow three he's a rich rapper that's what
i'm saying i'm saying and grants
like what are what are we talking about
if you're just yeah exactly
five two how tall go on grinder good
luck exactly if you're an accountant
what height do you want to be if you're
a plumber what height are you
not if you're if you want to be 60 do
you want to go to the bank teller and
he's six
nine i'm like what a terrible decision
look at that that's crazy look at that
man every rep little wayne is
five five lamar five six and you gotta
stand up yeah
peter dinklage four foot
i mean five eight bro
eminem five eight yeah i didn't realize
i didn't know that i didn't know he was
taller than some good company kanye is
five eight as well
louisiana had some height uh how tall is
silk the shocker
oh he's six foot oh master p was tall
too he played basketball
five eight yeah they play basketball we
talk about athletes now
now we're talking about six four silk
the shocker yeah yeah yeah no he died
now
he died shocked if you're short you're
living
yeah the shocker's dead wait wait wait
no no or does he see
murder no jail but he's in jail where's
the mystical
mistake all my heroes are still alive
those are your heroes yeah yeah talk
about partners in crime they might i
think some of those guys are dead
mystical this is only five eleven though
yeah damn let's go
50. have you watched the no limit uh
documentary nah
i heard it's good though yeah but i'm
kind of sad no limit was
they were talking about their hype bro
this is a tall batch of fellas right
there yeah
not like these other short ass rappers
from other places how tall is paul wall
five i'm gonna say five seven okay
well he seemed pretty tall i think he's
like paul walden no no no no
the brad is little i was six foot yeah
see yeah yeah
damn slim thug six six oh that's a big
but here's the thing though if you live
if you got a
if you've got a small height yeah if you
got a small height
then you have more chip on your shoulder
i think you might have more drive you
might have a little more combustion in
your with you that's what i'm saying i
agree with you
because if you're stretched out you're
long you might be more like oh
everything's
easy yeah chicks coming your way
and chicks and dude also my grandfather
there i am last night actually with a
yellow wolf yellow wolf he's tall
yellow one that was last night yeah what
were you guys doing
uh and gangsta boo right there um
i like yellow off yellow he's great and
that lady was in three six mafia too
the brat gangster boom that's not the
brad
not us damn juicy j in three uh
gangster boosters music video
and who else were they talking on the
phone that was pretty fun uh
yellow is only six foot he looks taller
than that booger chucky or something
some man named booger chucky
um but anyway what were we saying
we're talking about small and height
like you say you small guys
dude first of all were you at a concert
no they were in the studio i just went
to hang out for a little while oh word
booger chuck is the craziest name i feel
like
dude everybody had that kid in class
though who was a straight booger chucky
dude
who would pick his nose and look like he
was going to kill people later on in
life
we had one kid i swear this boy named
michael bro
he always had one one finger in his nose
and one eye on your [ __ ] heart
a little booger chucker
booger chucker booger chucky bro cause
chucky's a little killer
think about that chucky was a killer how
tall is chucky look it up
yeah that's right he's like two six i
think
but let's see they did a new one heard
some [ __ ]
chucky doll height 29 inches dude two
five i was one injured
you know your height hey bro and i bet
six hundred dollars on it
i bet you over on that booger chucky
height
dude you telling me little can't be
badass little chucky's little ass
29 inches of straight [ __ ]
silverware
murderboard okay yeah so you all need to
get it right all you out here
and look if you're tall you can't be a
[ __ ] murderer you can't
it's you right now easy i agree i didn't
seek you busted you ain't doing
[ __ ] everywhere you go you got to do
like this to make sure you don't hit a
[ __ ] shitty light at some point
he's asking to grab things for him
people meeting up at you at the
fairgrounds people all let's meet over
there by randall you're digging
everybody's face all the time like a
microphone
yeah you got to put deodorant on the
side of your nuts because of where your
nuts are in space to people's heads
stuff you got to think about man dude
you got to think more
little you show up nobody gives a [ __ ]
anyway you want to be tall ari after all
that
absolutely come on man i never did those
things i don't know what height
imagine only be able to have 11 people
at your church
if you're tall you could be a hero you
could save people out of trees and stuff
i've always wanted to be a hero
who's a little hero chin well your whole
your whole
culture that's true i mean before me the
people before me
yeah but not anymore not anymore now
we're getting real tall you're that game
breaker bro yeah
i am literally out of my whole family
you're the tallest asian i've ever seen
thank you appreciate it you're the
tallest asian i actually knew a guy
this was on a ship though you're the
tallest asian on land that i know
that's fair in person was it cruise ship
deal
land asian yeah this is cruise ship
you're i mean you're the dikembe mutumba
of koreans
but they're getting taller than me now
so i was like the i was like the
threshold breaking point
and now there's like getting super small
you have to have kids
now that they're taller not really all
right man i'll be fine
who's a little killer right there frodo
baggins right there
damn three six danny devito five four
genghis khan was five
one prince okay genghis khan anyway
people he killed people were shorter
back then i think yeah
did didn't mugsy bugs shoot somebody one
time he's five three no that was uh
marvin harris and killed somebody at a
car wall
you're right yes or it did
sunday no oh was 5'4
dude michael j fox back to the future
fight i know kevin hart was that little
look at seth green's little last woody
allen little touch
harry potter is only five
you're right saber bruno got a little
hug damn jack black it's only
five six look at all the talent and
short people man
aziz five six a lot of people trying to
jump five six yeah we're going to hell
man
[Laughter]
martin luther king jr we're not even to
your height yet he's only five
seven right william's five seven nothing
more but you know what i'm saying tom
cruise oh you said tom cruise is 5'7
yeah
al pacino spud whip dunk contest
manny pacquiao yeah and how tall are you
already five nine five nine
of these i'm feeling good they're making
me feel really good yeah yeah that's why
we brought you here
carlos they even include five nine i'm a
tall guy
yeah i'm one of you nine's average they
call you stretch on this list it's the
king and i stand